this week Daily Mirror reporter Thalia
shadow wrote about receiving unsolicited
pregnancy adverts on her Facebook
profile now that may not appear too
weird in itself that is until Thalia
revealed that she thought the only way
Facebook could have assumed that she was
pregnant was by following her period
tracker app on her phone which after her
last cycle she had simply forgotten to
update Thalia was not in fact pregnant
her data had erroneously communicated to
connected apps that she was without her
permission in a twist befitting the
Chinese social credit system insurers
are also already linking customers
premiums to their diet and health
tracking apps rewarding those who lead a
healthy lifestyle and penalizing those
who don't
surveillance capitalism and Chinese
surveillance communism pretty much
amount to the same ends both tear up
individual privacy and seek to commodify
the person now this great digital
revolution that we're in raises some
urgent questions about the kind of
future we wish to inhabit we must
resolve these questions before big
matron decides to monitor more than just
your periods majid and I don't use and
the thing is what we have to decide you
know I agree with everything you said
but there is no such thing as a free
lunch and there's no such thing as free
social media and as consumers we have to
decide if we want to use these platforms
for free and we don't want to pay we
have to accept that sadly when we sign
those terms and conditions we are paying
with our data so I think the bigger
conversation has to be around what we as
consumers are now expecting and actually
what we're going to the kind of
relationship we're going to have with
these platforms going forward and that
that's the conversation desperately need
and I think information and the
knowledge of what's going on will help
us in that conversation I mean how many
people know that say in China where they
do grade their citizens it's currently
voluntary it is in 2020 going to become
compulsory and they credit them in a way
that then you're buying a plane ticket
if you're seeking marriage if you want
to go to
University your score will affect
whether you can do something as simple
as get a train and currently in China
thirteen point four nine million people
thirteen point four nine million
citizens are classified as untrustworthy
by the state because of these social
credits that some insurance companies
are justing their premiums apps that are
diet and health apps you know we you
know we have we have companies with
period trackers they're using period
tracker so they can gauge woman's moods
at work to see and that suspect it's not
just for that I suspect that's to see if
they're using the doesn't excuse not to
come to this girl why does she need a
period tracker can she as you know got a
diary has she not got a memory can she
not put it on the calendar but you know
I am I feel like I'm part of a digital
generation technology is useful the
famous analysis of George Orwell in Big
Brother releasing everything right
except he assumed that the state would
take a date yes never imagined we would
give it away freely and I have to say I
feel like I make this and say I'm
wearing an Apple watch it tells me
everyday exercise burned enough calories
and you know you start actually
adjusting your movements to make sure
and the reason that I have that is it's
useful but the cost is that now Apple
knows how much what my heart rate gets
to see whether you point is I think just
to finish we come in neck okay agree
with you imagine I think but I think
that there is a really unrealistic
burden on consumers we need this
technology to do various things we need
email accounts we need to Google things
we need social media
and when we take all those consent boxes
the idea that we would read the full
contents I'm a lawyer for goodness sake
I do that I would read every single
thing I end up having to consent to
every day it's unrealistic it's not fair
to expect us to to fully process what
these companies are asking from us this
girl he's the period tracker yeah did
they explain that they would share it
with companies that might assume she was
pregnant and if I did did they do it in
a way that she could realistically I do
me in a moment here's what Facebook's
say there are a variety of reasons
someone may see ads related to specific
content on Facebook but Facebook does
not use behavior in apps to inform the
interest categories that serve you ads
furthermore we don't want websites or
apps sharing people's personal health
information with us it's a violation of
our rules and we enforce against these
breaches when we find evidence of third
parties doing this Facebook it's a
question actually for you imagine are we
suggesting therefore that there's
because this is only as a for right this
is only gonna get more probably
absolutely we need some kind of policing
regulation I mean this is how would it
be enforced right well so perhaps for
example one of the things to consider is
does Facebook really need to own
Instagram as well as Facebook as well as
say whatsapp because it stifles
competition but also accountability now
in answer to your question about what
the terms and conditions were she had
the the reporter in question Talia had
checked off that she wants to share her
data but in the small print that she
hadn't read and she's an educated
journalist it said okay we won't share
your personalized individualized data
but we will share your aggregated data I
don't know whether that's on a monthly
or quarterly basis and that still
indicates on an aggregated level that
she was I would not imagine that would
mean they could share the details of the
status of my room I mean it we all know
and it's it's how realistic it is for us
to really understand that
so Richard Stokes who is who's a
specialist in data privacy says every
move is being tracked and used to
manipulate what we read what we buy how
we vote and how we see the world by
using smart devices we have invited a
vast network of big tech companies
advertisers data brokers
governments and more into our homes and
pockets and with every post click and
purchase we have become the product I
think that consumers need to become more
mindful I'm sorry I do but I also agree
with you in that we need legislation in
a way I think it's a combination of but
I think the problem also is our
lawmakers don't understand the
technology so actually we need more
people in positions where they're
actually creating policies that actually
understand how these things working but
I know I responsibility for the way we
function as adults but what are a
meaningful alternatives for example if I
don't like Google's terms how else do I
find what I need to if I don't like
Facebook's and how do I connect we don't
have meaningful terms there's a level of
this which becomes not awful and that's
deep fakes now ultimately no matter what
we do let's take for example the recent
video that was put out the infamous one
on good morning Britain now if you just
watch oh you wouldn't know it's a
reworking of an interview with Jay so
kiss kiss Tama was giving an answer to
to a question about brexit and the
Conservative Party took his face but the
answer that he gave was cut out and they
just went straight to us still of his
face where he couldn't answer which is
probably from a different part of the
interview and it looked as if he didn't
know what to say about bricks and how
kids Dharma James clearly said it was
always meant as a piece of satire
talking about deep fakes which that
wasn't but it's a precursor to one you
can now make with technology to make
videos that appear a hundred percent
real I could be speaking and saying
something I've never said now that's not
there that's not about the consumer but
it's about kind of this dark world we're
about to enter which is Big Brother
where nobody knows what's real anymore
and when you don't know what's real when
when reality no longer has any meaning
then there's no basis for doing anything